REO is finally coming to the iphone yep
be pokemons go is coming to the watch
there was a big emphasis on gaming
around you know both the iphone and the
watch what do you make of it well I
think we're starting with the watch you
know there hasn't really been any
breakout games really right that's taken
off i think pokemon go makes a lot of
sense on this product mean i'm going to
use it like crazy to catch pokemon on my
on my wrist but the increase that
they're giving in process and
performance in the GPU are opening up
those those visual opportunities on your
risk for developers so the first is that
the performance upgrade we're seeing
will give more software opportunity for
your wrist so i think now the floodgate
can open for apps and we'll see where
developers take that now the performance
has gotten there and mario is just a
good i think a good example of a
franchise and hopefully perhaps this was
in the works longer than this but
hopefully between pokemon go and mario
you know nintendo is learning how to
embrace the mobile error and to do so in
a way with that brings their franchise
to more people in more places and makes
it accessible on the devices we have in
our pocket every day quickly horas we
just have 20 seconds do you think this
opens up a new category of customer that
Apple didn't have before you know I
actually just to make one plug I think
the nike thing is even bigger I mean
nike and the partnership they doing with
our maze are just precursors to a whole
new game that Apple is playing as a
partner and and the team player with
other companies which never happened in
the Steve Jobs there this is absolutely
amazing what they're doing as a partner
big big change fitness